Well let's figure this out together. In this loop i traverses all rows. In this
nested loop for each row j traverses all columns and we need to figure out x
and y. Let's look at our picture. As i goes zero, one, two, three and so on the
y position goes 30, 60, 90 and so on. So the y values are 30 times i. I should
really be using this constant over here so let me fix that up and for the same
reason the x values of width times j. What are our blue and green? Let's look
at the picture again as I goes larger of the row index, the blueness increases.
When I add 0 blueness is 0. When i is the maximum value of 15, the blueness is
255. So in general, i is 255 divided by the largest value for i. Notice the -1.
There's 16 rows, numbered 0 to 15. And at the 15th one we want the full value
of 255. The formula for the greens is exactly analogous. When j is zero, green
is zero. When j is 15, we have 15 times 255 over 15 or 255. And for values in
between, the green grows as j does. Again, the point of this example was that
you need two nested loops to control the rows and the columns.